these are beef short ribs and there's
basically five to six bones across there
and as the short rib cooks it sticks
that bone the bone implants flavor and
the meat just sort of melts cook slowly
gives it that nice level intensity slice
alongside the bone stray down you can
see that marbling that sort of
disappears and disintegrates I'm cooking
them in a roasting tray get it on the
heat until nice and hot seasoned beef
short ribs beautifully olive oil in both
on the top we'll start coloring that in
[Music]
really important to give the beef short
rib a really nice sear if you didn't
brown the meat off it goes in the oven
and it looks like boiled meat so you
really want that not only stark rich
coloring just cut the garlic 1/2 slide
that down the side it's gonna give that
beef an amazing flavor to give body to
the sauce stir in a heaped teaspoon of
tomato puree I'm just hitting the bottom
of the pan without some out of fury and
we call it cooking out of smart puree
otherwise it just goes in there raw and
it gives this sort of tartness for the
braised short ribs red wine in
don't use an expensive bottle of red
wine there's no needs bring the wine up
to the boil and reduce it this burns off
the alcohol and concentrates the flavor
it makes a big difference when you
reduce the red wine down by half because
it gives that nice dark rich intensity
what am i guard it that it's just a
sweet everything up
incredible stock in leave stop perfect
chicken stock fine
just to about an inch underneath the
beef short ribs bringing up to the ball
to lock in all that flavor as the beef
ribs slow cook cover them so they braise
from the bottom and steam from the top
into the oven
between half hours 170 to 180 degrees in
she goes the great thing about slow
cooking is you do most of the work in
advance and then put your feet up five
or ten minutes before did beef short
ribs come out of the oven start your
garnish this is like cured pancetta
but what nice thick lardons nice big
thick sticks of crispy bacon
[Music]
these are delicious and chestnut
mushrooms along with sliced me just
gonna cut them in half look at the color
on those lardons now all the whites raw
fat I've disappeared
alarms are shrunk right down and all
we've got there now is the proper bacon
mushrooms in beautiful so the mushrooms
get seasons from the bacon I'm Pam
frying these separately to the beef so
their main crisp another different
texture leave that to cool down now this
is like Christmas Day for me when you
unwrap that fall wait you see what's
underneath it
mmm-hmm Wow smell incredible
lift place on your tray beautiful
to make a fantastic rich deep sauce
press the stop roasted garlic through a
sieve into the cooking juices that nice
pureed garlic coming through there as
that it's gonna make the most amazing
life scrape all that off the sieve nice
then just start sitting all that lovely
braising liquor well in
that smells delicious take your sauce
and just glaze do them individually they
deserve that respect spoon on your bacon
and your mushrooms you should be
generous with these mushrooms I'm
telling you they taste amazing flat leaf
parsley all that freshness over those
amazing ribs incredible never ever be
embarrassed about going to your butcher
and asking for cheap cuts because the
results are incredible amazing beef
braised short ribs with bacon and
mushrooms
pour in hot water to braise the brisket
[Music]
bay leaf and delicate strands of saffron
then fry to release all the aromatic
flavors next